think we definitely do need to create a
more sex positive culture because sex is
natural that's how we're created this
it's something that we can't help but
it's how we you know cultivate that and
get into that I.E not sleeping with
loads of people that's to the guys as
well I've got young sons and I try to
teach them to be celibate put your
energy into your sports and into your
careers and hopefully when you elevate
you can give yourself to a woman that
you know is decent but also you've got
all the STIs and STDs whatever they're
called and the section like the energy
transfer and I think in that way we need
to be more educated it's not about like
oh sex is bad sex is not bad we're not
gonna stop and I think because we
haven't really taken on face value in
that case sex is natural this is why we
do have all the corn and you know the
essay and whatever because we're
restricted and we feel dirty and it's
not like it's natural just find one
person that you Vibes with and you know
build that relationship with them get to
know each other